and finally new rule when a dentist has
60 grand to drop on a safari
that's when we know there's too much
sugar in the soda
you know i don't mind it when really
rich people act like [ __ ]
well actually i do mind i mind a lot but
what can you do
of course it wasn't right when donald
trump's [ __ ] son
douchevon shitheal trump iii
snuffed out the life of another
beautiful animal to forget about his
tiny dick but
i understand it because he's really rich
but a [ __ ]
dentist gets to do this your office is
in a strip mall next to a korean nail
salon you make a living scraping plaque
off people's teeth
and by the way if you're a dentist
itching to travel to another continent
to kill something
next time grow some balls go to syria
and take on isis
you know we
do have a moral crisis in america but it
doesn't come from saggy pants or gay
wedding cakes or hillary's emails
it comes from worshiping obscene wealth
so much that posing next to the carcass
of an endangered species
is a way of saying hey look at me
i'm a soulless prick just like the super
rich
this wasn't even about the lion next
year it'll be buying a bottle of wine
for 10 grand or
crashing a sports car into a chuck e
cheese or
hiring a sherpa to lug your fat ass up
mount everest
you see you see in america being
filthy rich is the greatest good but if
you're a dentist you're not
rich like that but if you save up
a couple of times a year you can splurge
on something ridiculous and at least
look like it
because in the game of america where
money counts for everything
this is how you let other people know
you won
because you did something horrible and
stupid that only rich people can get
away with
we always hear about the sick culture of
poverty what about the sick culture of
wealth
last uh last halloween there was an
anonymous letter printed in slate from a
wealthy homeowner who complained about
trick-or-treaters from other
neighborhoods
knocking on his door he said halloween
isn't a social service or a charity in
which
i have to buy candy for less fortunate
children
wow save some scrooge for christmas
or take the example of what's going on
here in california where we're having a
little problem with water
there isn't any when james taylor comes
here and sings i've seen
fire and i've seen rain he just says
fire
we are living through the worst drought
since the 1800s when jerry brown started
keeping records
but when governor brown asked everyone
to cut water usage by
25 water usage in the wealthy enclave of
rancho santa fe
went up local douchebag steve youhass
said
we pay significant property taxes based
on where we live and
no we're not all equal when it comes to
water people should not be forced to
live on property with brown lawns and
golf on brown courses yes the only brown
thing allowed on steve's golf course is
the caddies
what are you brewing me for
and now they applaud me for giving them
the finger
and interior designer gay butler chimed
in what are we supposed to do just have
dirt around our house on our four acres
yes that's that's what land is
it's dirt what did you think was under
the grass tile
here's what my lawn looks like now who
gives a [ __ ]
didn't change my life at all and by the
way if there really is an interior
designer named gay butler
somewhere there must be a gay butler
named interior designer
now i'm sure that the majority a very
rich people
have always been greedy and selfish but
this crowd today
takes it to a whole new level somehow
it's not enough to spend lavishly on
themselves
they have to actively take from others
their water
their benefits the last bits of beauty
in the world
in his non-apology apology dentist the
lion hunter
used the word legal over and over what
he did was legal
sure because the rich buy politicians to
write laws
to say that whatever they want is legal
right
like our elections now more than half
the money given to presidential
candidates so far has come from just 400
families
perfectly legal but you know for that
kind of money
the rich shouldn't just get to tell
politicians what to do
i think they should get to hunt them
that would be the ultimate trophy to go
with your trophy kill
and your trophy car and your trophy wife
what could be better than a trophy
republican candidate's head on your wall
scott walker's
scott walker's eyes already look like
cheap taxidermy and
chris christie's leg would make a lovely
umbrella stand
and if that sounds wrong we'll make a
law that says it's legal
thank you very much
you